I am really,
really excited to bring on stage Rochelle
Brisco who was an HR people partner
here at Youtube.
We've got Teraji coming on stage who,
I don't think it needs an introduction.
We've got Robin Bissell who was the
writer and director of this very amazing
movie, the best of enemies. And then
we've also got Dominique telson coming on.
Who produced this moving please
from them.
Well, as you can tell from
that, very warm welcome.
We're so excited to have all of you here.
Um,
everyone has just seen an amazing
clip from the best of enemies.
And this was four years ago when we
first heard that you signed on to Raj,
you to be part of the film.
Um,
can you tell us a little bit about
the process, you know, when you see,
when you saw this, what made you
decide that this was right for you?
Well, Danny Strong, um, co Creator,
one of the Co creators and producers
of Empire gave me this script when we
filmed the pilot for empire.
And then
the show became a big success and
it was hard for me to, you know,
schedule my schedule. I had so many
scheduling conflicts. And then, um,
it was after the 2016 election,
I noticed that the racial
climate change drastically.
So I called Danny and I was like,
we have to make this movie
and we got to make it now.
And at the time I was already slated
to do, I'm proud Mary on my hiatus.
And so he was like, you already have
a movie. And I was like, I don't care.
Make it happen. Make the dates work
and I'll give up my entire hiatus.
And that's what I did.
That's fantastic. And Robin, you'd
produce some amazing blockbusters,
sea biscuit,
the hunger games Pleasantville.
But this is your directorial
debut? Yeah. Like for you,
what made this your first,
how'd you choose [inaudible]?
What was the story I'd
first heard about in 2005.
And so I had been really anxious to
do something with it at the time.
You know,
as a producer you have to find a writer
and a director and do all that to have
something come to fruition.
But after the hunger games,
I had been thinking about wanting to,
because I started out as a singer,
song writer way back in the
90s. Um, and so, you know,
I fancied myself a creative, so
I'm, so after the hunger games,
that was my time.
I thought about directing and this is
the one thing I just been wanting to do,
just tell the story regardless
of how I was involved.
And so I sat down and I
called my friend Danny Strong,
said I'm going to start
writing this. And uh, I did.
Yeah. Yeah. And what about you Dominique?
Had you worked with Robin or Teraji
before? How'd you decide to produce? No,
I hadn't, I hadn't worked
with either one, but, um,
actually what another one of
Robin's friends, Matt Berenson,
I think they were tennis partners,
is what he told me. Said, yeah,
my friend Robert gave me the script. So
he read it and then he sent it to me. And,
uh, when I read it, I was like,
I want to make this movie. Um, I,
I just, I just fell in love with the
character of Ann Atwater. And of course,
like everyone else,
Google did that she really exists.
Is this really a real person?
And I'm just was fascinated
by what she was able to do,
um, in her community, um,
with, with, with this film.
And then it just in her, in her
life at, you know, as a woman,
uh, you know, in this, in this
town. And so I, I made it,
my goal is make thanks for doing it.
Not just did she exists,
but I understand some of you had a
chance to meet her before her passing and
so when I, um, I'm sorry,
did I interrupt you?
Do you know of another second half of the
question? Um, yeah. So, uh, right after I,
I re optioned the book cause I had let
the option lapse in 2009 I reactions book
in 2013 and I beelined it for Durham and
I called Ann and she was very open and,
and she was in the hospital at
the time. She hurt her knee. Um,
and so we just started having lunch and
talking and I'd go back and then I kept
going back. And then bill
Riddick also who's still alive,
I just started spending time
with them and um, you know,
Anne was just sharp as a tack till the,
literally up until she passed in 2016.
It's a big regret.
We didn't get to get it done before
because she was so excited at first.
She was so excited that Taraji was
going to play her, I mean beyond,
um, and she was just so excited for the
movie to yeah, really a wonderful woman,
really wonderful and really gave
me a lot of perspective, uh,
as a filmmaker into not just herself,
but what it was like in the 50s,
sixties and seventies in,
in the south end. Great Perspective
on CP wasn't alive anymore. Uh,
and seeing it through her eyes allowed
me to three dimensionalize him more.
So yeah,
we got a few of them. I mean the families,
uh, came on set and, and were there,
Bill [inaudible] was there during the
Charette, you know, so, you know, he,
he helped a lot cause you, you know,
you watch this and you go like,
how did this happen? He goes, when I met
them, I couldn't stand either one of them.
They was both nasty. And so it was,
it was kind of great to see that,
that perspective. Cause it again,
three dimensionalize the story that,
that Robin had written in
his, in his screenplay. Um,
and then they all came
to this, the all the, um,
his children and grandchildren and her
children and grandchildren came to the
premier that we had. We had a screening
in Durham for them and they were really,
really supportive of the film, which
was, which was great. That's amazing. Um,
yeah, it, it definitely comes
alive. It's three dimensional,
you feel every bit of it.
And one of the areas that really struck
me was just how extreme there are
some of the scenes and it's this very
severe optimism matched shortly with
severe pessimism. And for
you to Raji and you, Robyn,
how,
how do you embody that in a character and,
and create that as a director? Uh, I mean,
well I couldn't really add too much
because Anne was a really a real person.
Um, I just listened to a lot of
the stuff people say about her, uh,
that she was a powerhouse.
Roughneck Annie,
a CP all would always say you
could hear her before you see her.
Um, she had a big mouth, you
know, so, you know, those,
those are real specific, uh,
descriptions of a person.
And that sounds like somebody that
doesn't take no for an answer.
That sounds like somebody that, um,
that gets things done, you know.
And the fact that she went up against
so many powerful white men and she was
unafraid, like she was fearless.
She would die for the cause.
That's how important it was for her to
leave this world in a much better place
than she found it for her children
and for generation after her. Um,
and she wasn't rich. She wasn't a
rich woman. She, she had no money,
but,
uh,
she had compassion in her heart and she
was a true Christian cause as Christians,
you supposed to love your enemy.
It's hard to do. But she did it,
you know, um, she just didn't
back down. I mean, Cook Gracious.
I couldn't imagine just when I,
when I,
um, had to get hurt when I
had the physical lies are,
I just imagined her when she gets,
she moved with a purpose, you know,
this is a woman who whenever she's moving,
she's moving with a purpose and
I just imagine a locomotive,
you know what I mean? And if you get in
her way, she's going to steam roll you.
So I just thought about things
like that. And, you know,
at the time it was so desperate, you
know, it was like her, the, you know,
poor people and black people in
particular in that community,
their backs were against the wall.
You know,
what happens when you back somebody up
into a corner, they come out swinging,
you know, and, and I just kept that
on board every time that, you know,
she wasn't just fighting for
herself and for her children,
she was fighting for the next
generation, you know. Um,
and that's a heavy weight to carry.
I, and she was just talking about their
backs are against the wall and what your
question was, which was the juxtaposition
of pessimism and optimism. And you know,
we live in such a pessimistic time now.
You know,
we talk about how we first heard the
story years ago and it was relevant then.
And, and I think that, that this,
you know, in these kinds of times,
and then,
you know,
the smallest bit of hope really can
save you even in an hour or a day,
you know, have the smallest bit of hope.
It's like, oh my God, it might be okay.
And that the embrace, they
embrace optimism, even when the,
it's a terrible, you know,
landscape. And you know,
these people were the same way I think.
And, and, you know, we talked about it,
we were charging and I, and Dominic were
talking about last night how, you know,
these weren't just,
you know,
they were poor and they were in a small
town derms of relatively small town,
but they were leaders within that town,
you know.
And so it's no accident that it's,
there was a trickle down effect from
some people who had change of heart.
You know, I mean, generational,
we've been meeting with CPS family and
his kids and grandkids is no hate in them.
I mean, they're wonderful people. And
that stopped because of an stopped him.
And so it's, it's, you
look at these people,
Bill Riddick was a leader and
Atwater was a leader who had,
people would follow her
to the ends of the earth,
but she had her own ideology as far
as shutting herself off to certain
conversation.
CP obviously on the wrong side,
but he had a lot of people
that would follow him.
So Bill Riddick was able to work on Ann
Atwater to have a resume and a little c,
little bit of some of the bigger picture
because she had made such a difference
in people's lives. And this will allow
her to tap into CP who was another leader.
And she knew if she could tap into him,
maybe that would trickle down. Right?
And it's because it's courage of
leadership is courage of moral courage.
And you know, that's what
we're missing today. I mean,
you know, do you know,
there's plenty of leaders,
we know plenty of our people in
Washington who know there's a gun problem,
who knows? There's a problem
with a in law enforcement, right?
We know there's a racial problem.
No, there's a climate problem.
They know they're not stupid,
right? But where's the courage?
Where's the courage to lead,
you know, the right way. So,
yeah, we have to dig into
that ourselves as people. Um,
I'm going to ask a little more
personally because you know,
I did spend 16 years in the beltway,
so I'm going to stay away from
that for this conversation. Um,
but in your own personal experience,
is there something that you drew from
or thought about when you're agreeing to
be in produce direct this story?
Okay.
I guess for me it was just,
um,
what made it so important for me
and why I gave up my entire hiatus.
She never lets me forget that.
Is it because, um, I mean, you know,
you see this world and as an artist I
feel like it is our duty to reflect the
times. That's, that's what we're
supposed to do with artists.
And I take that responsibility
very seriously. Um,
art has changed my life.
I have looked at a visual painting and
it has touched me to the core or shifted
my perspective or something,
you know, artists that powerful.
So whenever I pick roles, you
know, some may be for fun,
but a lot of them, if you
pay close attention, uh,
it's examples of something to leave for
our kids or a message to change a group
of people's perception on another
group of people. You know,
the more stories that we tell,
the more we are aware that different
stories and different people exist.
And until we don't have to make stories
like this where we have to put a mirror
up to society and say, Hey, not looking so
good, clean it up, you know, and then we,
we, we will continue to make
these films. They're important.
This is how you push humanity forward.
So this is why I did the film.
I felt that it was like a great
responsibility of mine as an artist.
Hmm. And, uh, I guess as a, as a
producer, when I, when I read the script,
um,
I had,
I have three daughters and they're
coming up in this world and you know,
it can be, it can be tough. And S, um,
when I saw this example of an out water,
that's the message I wanted them to know,
to have that hope that look at
this woman and she was fierce and,
and just kept going and
had the courage to do what,
what really no one else,
what no one else did.
And I want them to have the hope that
if you, if you put yourself into it,
maybe there is hope, hope
for change. I mean, you know,
she was known as Rough House Annie,
but in order to reach CP,
she had to step back from being rough
house Annie and found a new way.
She had to find a way to, to,
he says this all the time,
but to his heart and soul and
that's what she, what she did.
And actually that takes a lot more,
more courage than it sometimes is to
just kind of, you know, be rough house.
So, um, I, I love this film
because of that. I want,
I want them to see that and I want the
world to, you know, to, to see this film.
And by the way, last thing, as a producer,
I love having diversity in
front of and behind the camera.
And we did that in Atlanta and uh,
we had a great crew and it
was a real family on set.
And I think part of the reason is
because of our diversity on set,
even though we were dealing with
a rough subject matter, you know,
we could look around and say, you know
what, w w we can, we can do this together.
Yeah, I mean, for me,
uh, initially was, um,
how, you know, I kept thinking about how
we put labels on each other, you know,
and it's weak. We define each other and
like little catch phrases, you know?
And without even knowing each other,
I do it too. I watch TV or, you know,
I get angry just like everyone else.
And you put up these barriers
right away when you get angry.
And I learned to be a better listener.
I think through this process. Um, we,
you know,
as artists,
we don't always get to make films that
are entertaining and are relevant or,
and have this kind of, you know,
power message. Sometimes we do.
It's okay not to, but
you know, and so, um,
for people, you know, be in
this two dimensional world,
we're not really listening to each other.
And we know that when you make a movie,
you know, you get to put, you know,
your people are in a dark room for two
hours just listening and not talking.
That's, uh, that's, you don't get
that opportunity very often. Right.
And so if we can do it right and have
people engage and become emotionally
invested in,
in the real lives of these characters,
and then we can say something that we
want to say and what they wanted to say,
that's a, that's a huge platform to be
able to have, you know, and that, that,
that's why, um, it, it, that's why I
love doing this. I mean, really. Yeah.
That's the hope that I felt.
I mean,
being fortunate enough to get a chance
to watch the movie and recognize that
maybe yeah,
maybe it's possible to have real severe
differences and somehow get past that.
It seems like from your answers,
you all really believe that it's still
possible for people to be diametrically
opposed and on very different sides of
the line. But to make a change today.
Absolutely. I mean, God is
very clever. You know, I'm,
I'm not going to preach
to anybody today, but, um,
I mean if you believe in a
higher power, God, I like to say,
um, if there was only supposed to
be one race, all God mighty God,
it would only be one race. God
is very clever. We all are here.
We look different.
We come from different backgrounds,
paying attention for a reason,
and it's for us to figure it out.
That's our job on life, in life,
to figure it out, to work it out.
And unfortunately we have
this thing called social
media and it has driven a big
divide between us because you would think,
yeah,
I can have a great conversation
on Twitter, but it goes
sour each and every time.
I just see a bunch of
people dragging each other.
No one's really listening
for understanding. Um,
and it's a world of clickbait real quick.
Soon as you hear one thing,
everybody jumps on and they're
believing and it's like,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Hey. Just from one phrase,
everybody believes this and it's just
like, it's like, it feels like it's chaos,
but it's up to us to get it together and,
and figure it out because
we're here for a reason.
We are, we are, we are. I say Amen to you.
Um, you know, I am tasked
today with, you know,
I had a girlfriend say, you guys
going to talk about this amazing film,
civil rights and mental health.
How are you going to do this?
This is Teraji this woman does
everything. Yeah, no, yeah,
we're gonna make this work. And
you know, I, I recognize this,
this period for you. You've done
things in this space, you know,
our civil rights era for African Americans
with hidden figures and now with the
best of enemies. And, and your father
grew up in the civil rights time.
Did, did he share his
background stories with you?
No, it was rough. I mean,
he's, he, um, one time he had,
I mean my dad who I was, she was
alive to tell his story, but you know,
Vietnam vet, um, uh, come,
coming back with mental issues.
So he had a couple run ins with
the law that landed him in jail,
in and out of, um, the
mental institution. You know,
anytime you go to war, you never
come back the same, you know,
but my father was an open book. He
didn't hide anything from me. Um,
and he was very open and honest
about his mental state, you know, um,
he was able to really work through it
and overcome it all. But, you know,
it was a huge adjustment after coming
back from Vietnam. It took a while,
you know, but, um, I like again, I mean,
you can't grow if you sweep
everything under the carpet.
And that's my pain for the
African American community.
We have generational trauma that we don't
deal with and we're walking around as
if everything is okay and it's
not, we're walking around of, of,
of generations of,
of,
of issues and trauma swept under the
carpet and we're standing on top of it as
if everything's fine. Yeah, you're
right. And it's, it's generational.
It's impacted some things we don't
even know are in effect a affecting us
because it's so embedded in us, we
don't even know. Yeah. And I mean,
and outside of your artist's
career, I mean, last year
you opened up a foundation.
Yeah. And your father's name [inaudible].
Can you tell us about its mission?
The mission is to, to, um,
work with the recidivism and prison
systems. Um, because no, you know,
you know, the prison system is not
really a place for reform or to,
uh,
get your life together and be
implemented back out into society.
A changed person.
It's really nice to keep you there.
And it's unfortunate
because a lot of people,
they are having mental issues and they
shouldn't even be in cages. Um, and then,
you know,
we have to,
I said I was a substitute teacher
before I booked baby boy and became a,
a a an act, an actress, you know, that
was my gig and I mean for, I made it,
you know,
uh,
but I took it very seriously and I chose
to work with special education children
and in my mind, I thought
that meant a disabled children
in wheelchairs, you know,
that can't eat or dress themselves.
And I get sent to Crenshaw and I get him
in a classroom with all black boys who
are labeled special Ed. But nothing's
wrong with them. They can walk,
they can talk, you know, they smart
out the mouth and I tell them,
let's start our work and they do
this. I'm special Ed. I can't do that.
So just because they have this label,
they already have a low expectation of
themselves and they believe it and it
broke my heart. So then, you know,
that's stood. I carry that with me for
so many years and all of this success.
And so when I came to launch
this foundation and I was like,
we need counselors, not just
counselors, but professional therapist,
psychiatrist that can go into these
schools and recognize that these children
are coming from traumatic experiences at
home and we're expecting them to learn.
Another thing that ha that I've
been carrying for years. Uh,
when I went to this acts, same school, um,
the children are taken me down a hall
and they're like, Ms. Henson, look,
it was a shoot out here last night
and they showed me the bullets and the
bullets and the wall. And I'm like,
and they're walking around like,
this is normal. So you
see what I mean? This is,
we're expecting these
children to come home from,
God knows these experiences they're
having at home trauma and they're
traumatized trying to
come to school and learn.
And then when they don't focus in class,
we slap a label on them
and say they're special Ed.
But we don't try to understand why.
When I started talking to these
young boys, one was found,
um,
roaming around by the train tracks,
which is in the backyard of the school
by the way, which is another issue,
trying to keep them, you know, a focus.
Then they got a train running through
the backyard every day that you know,
a whole lot of issues.
But anyway,
he was roaming around the train tracks.
He got picked up for
shoplifting at the seven 11.
He was trying to get something to eat
because his mother was on drugs and his
father was in prison.
How does that make you special ed?
You can still learn.
You just have trauma at home.
So we need to implement a
psychiatrist and, and who are in,
in these schools who can recognize the
trauma and give these children the proper
care that they need as opposed to just
labeling them special ed and getting them
ready for the prison system.
So we're dealing with that.
And we're also giving away scholarships
to young African American children
because see, we don't talk about it
at home is taboo in our community.
So a lot of times our kids don't even
know that this is a field to study it.
This is something I can even go into
because we're not even talking about it at
home.
So we need more African American and not,
it's not even about a color
because I see therapists, you know,
I need it and it's okay.
I'll be the first one to tell you
it's okay to not be okay. But, um,
it's not even about a color is
cultural competency. So if you,
I can, I can understand
another, uh, cultures, uh,
problems if I take the time to.
But see,
a lot of times you have these therapists
who are coming from other countries or,
and they just want the car to
come here and practice. So again,
you have these people in these positions
that really don't even want to be there.
So it's a lot to, it's a lot to
cover, but at least we're talking now.
At least we're talking. Yeah. Thank
you for helping that conversation.
You're wondering why and that
we're, or you're not. Well,
you know what I wanted to Razi
to play her. Exactly. Call
me the cookie lady cookie
lady. Go and play me.
Yeah. This, this is, this is a
modern civil rights issue, you know,
in communities now. Um, the,
the difference in a time of crisis
from an appropriate training, you know,
deescalation,
we have this now with officers to
recognize the difference in violence and
mental health. It's
something that, you know,
we say civil rights era but were
still living in this right now and,
and mental health isn't,
you know,
something that's just stigmatized in the
African American community, you know,
across countries, communities, classes,
there are stigmas associated with
talking about it, addressing it, um,
sharing that it's okay to
be okay. Um, for you all,
I mean, before or after this film,
have you ever had to confront these,
these stigmas around mental health,
around needing to get help,
encouraging someone to get help and have,
how do you all address it?
I, my sister went through
a terrible divorce and she,
she actually went through
something for a while.
There was the first time in our family
that we had to deal with that and you
know, my parents are from the old
school, you know, east coast. You know,
I grew up in suburbs kind of
sheltered and um, you know,
they didn't really want to talk
about it and I, you know, I was like,
what do you mean it's okay, we can talk,
but this wasn't that long ago, you know,
and everything's fine. But
it was, um, you know, uh,
there was a stigma, you know,
if for us it was, you know,
everything was okay.
Don't talk about,
well that's no good because
then we're not asking for help.
It's okay to ask for help. And I
think that's the, that's where the,
any kind of stigma hurts.
It's that you don't ask for help.
Asking for help was everything
we see. I mean, we've had what,
a couple of high profile suicides lately,
you know,
just the last couple of weeks it's been
horrible. And that's trauma and tries.
She's talking about trauma,
you know,
our brains are so fragile or
emotions are fragile. There's,
there's trauma we don't really know about.
It's not just coming home from war,
it's not, you know what I mean? And so I,
you know, I can't begin to understand it,
but I do know that when
you get rid of stigma,
people will ask for help, you know?
And, and as a father, I have two boys,
one's here at Berkeley, and I
tell him all the time, you know,
if it's okay to ask me if anything is
the matter, you know what I mean? Don't,
don't be too strong or don't try
to be, you know, so is is is,
I'm sorry this is something that
gets under my skin and, and, and,
and so many people need this help but
it just seems like it's set up and
designed to make it as
difficult as possible for you
to get the hell I'm talking
even within the Sag insurance.
That's something I'm ready to tackle.
Like why is it that I can't use my
insurance to pay for my psychiatrist?
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah. My psychiatrist broke that
down to me. She was like, you know,
you have this amazing insurance program,
Blue Cross Blue Shield
Blue Shield does cover me,
but for whatever reasons I'm outside
of network for Sag. Go figure.
Like what are we doing here?
We are fortunate and blessed to have you
all a few tackling these issues on the
screen off of the screen. Thank
you for being here. This, you know,
we could talk about this for a while
obviously, but you know, for our audience,
for, for all of the audiences out there,
if I could ask each of you to, you know,
as a final question,
uh,
what do you want people to take away
from this film? I want people to see you,
the film and you know, you know,
be inspired, you know, be inspired,
be inspired to look at your neighbor.
I think we were talking before about,
you know, Twitter wars and
whatever, but you know,
if you really have to look the other
person in the eye and really have a
conversation, you know, maybe there's
something we can do with that. Um,
and that's what I hope
people are inspired by,
by Ann and what she was able
to do. Um, and my s you know,
by the transformation that
CP made and have hope that,
that maybe we can,
we can come out of this and
the next generation is left
a little better off then.
And then ours is right now. I mean,
honestly, I'm looking out at your,
at your audience here and
it's, it's wonderful to see. I,
when I started working corporate, it did
not look like this. No, we're youtube.
But you said you feel proud on the
stage to have the back, you know,
behind the scenes. This is us, this
is behind the scenes and we're proud.
A lot of people put in a lot of
work. Graduation is, I, I've,
I've worked corporate jobs. This
doesn't look like this. And you know,
it's just so, so that's what I, that's,
I hope that this is possible because
of that. She doesn't even know this,
but when I came to the country,
I didn't speak English,
so I got put in special ed and then they,
and then I was like,
I just didn't speak the language.
Just didn't, then I had to get tests.
There's nothing wrong with me, you
know, just, just teach me English
is crazy.
They will,
you ready for the prison
bag that she's in the movie business?
For me it's the same thing. Like there's
so many things talk about this story,
right? We can talk about
it all day, like you said.
But really what worked
here was a charette, right?
And um, and so what Dominique
was saying, when you,
when you sit in front of someone,
even if you start arguing,
you're not going to argue forever. You
really let down your defenses when you,
you're not as aggressive when you,
you know,
you see people in road rage videos now,
which I've watched a lot on youtube
cause it's really fun. Uh, but,
but I've gone through
these really me. So, uh,
you see what people say to each other
when they're behind that the glass,
you know what I mean?
But you stand up and you walk to someone,
you're not going to say those things. You
know what I mean? Some people I guess,
but you know, and so you sit down and
you start talking to people and oh,
you have children. Oh
you like this. And Oh,
you went to school here
and all you grew up here,
he started forgetting your differences.
And you might still have them,
but you can talk about it respectfully.
You can find common ground.
It's not brain surgery. It might be
brain surgery to get us all together.
But once you're there, you let that
and you let down your veneer, you know,
and you just start seeing each other as
human beings. It's just what happens.
So when I was encouraged,
you know,
and we were just coming out on April
5th I think we will all be encouraged.
Thank you. Thank you for the movie.
Thank you for your foundation.
Thank you for this time today.
Thank you for having us,
Robin.
[inaudible].